[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
on va parler de l'actualité des îles et
jaune naturellement la situation des
mères en france est-ce que c'est facile
d'être en mer ou difficile c'est sans
doute difficile et parfois certains sont
un peu désespéré on va parler aussi de
ceux qui rendent possible la possible
c'est le titre d'un livre d'un maire
justement le maire de poissy karl olive
bonjour bonsoir catrice vous êtes
l'auteur avec arnaud bout sur berg d'un
livre qui s'appelle donc rendre possible
l'impossible en parler c'est un portrait
de 16 personnalités comme sécurité des
stades soient français destin soit
extraordinaire donc qu'ils soient qu'ils
sont sortis de leur milieu
on va on va parler dans quelques
instants avec vous aussi mustapha
larbaoui sortie ou si vous avez vu votre
destin et revient on en parlera aussi un
petit peu et dans un milieu qui vous
protègent leurs destinées pas de
jeunesse massira
je laisse le dire non je voulais parce
que je les ai vécus dont je ne vois pas
comme extraordinaire je le vois comme
l'ayant vécu effectivement il ya des
c'est un parcours qui était pas aussi
évident mais pour l'avoir vécu je
considère que c'est normal avec doa
licencie cost qu'ils que je suis ravi
d'accueillir vous êtes américaine vous
dirigez vous avez fondé l'académie of
corporate inglis et à rambouillet vous
donner notamment des cours aux
entreprises pour pratiquer l'anglais du
business c'est plutôt ça et que vous
êtes américaine ça m'intéresse d'avoir
aussi votre regard sur ce qui se passe
en fond sur les mouvements et vous non
pas le rec
et puis jean charles lajoie dit bonsoir
vous n'êtes pas effet racheté les
éditions ballon
à une époque c'est vrai c'est drôle
le livre de livres de cartes brive est
publié aux éditions balland absolue mais
vous avez finalement au fondé les
éditions la joie ni voilà et vous
publiez plutôt des polars oui et on voit
que des polars mais mais mais pas le
m'aimait beaucoup de possible d'aller en
des temps c'est un polar pur pur et dur
une clinique si accueillant une clinique
si accueillants c'est un peu une une
image est pas vrai elle n'est pas
vraiment accueillante le sillage des
choses traînent cela posé il ya une une
héroïne très très curieuse qui ressemble
un peu à l'héroïne de deux millenium un
rythme aussi de vie aussi étrangers papa
dans son côté geek mais plutôt dans son
côté totalement allumés très bonne
enquête ça se passe à brest c'est
franchement un très très bon polar
alors on va peut-être commencer par un
autre livre qui ait sévi de de karl
olive et d'arnaud bouchard berg rendre
possible l'impossible j'ai dit et c'est
le portrait de 16 personnalités que vous
avez choisi tissot alors qu'ils sont au
milieu de parcours différents mais que
des parcours assez exceptionnel il ya
ceux qui ont par exemple subi des
handicaps très difficile je pense
notamment à philippe croizon amputé des
quatre membres et qui est devenu voilà
un aventurier de la possible il ya un
préfet qui est devenu préfet y en a
qu'un en france monsieur parizeau
parisot alors il ya des gens qui sont
sortis de leurs milieux d'origine je
pense à zahia ziouani que je te déclic
est assez formidable qui est devenu qui
était dans le 9-3 comme on dit qui
devenu chef d'orchestre de cette pièce
classique
il ya aussi des grands sportifs alors
est ce qu'il faut rêver comme qu'il y
ait même map et comme comme didier
deschamps et puis votre livre est
préfacé par quelqu'un qui connaît un peu
en est-on en train de paris qui
s'appelle le
monsieur emmanuel macron président de la
république et nos serveurs préface
emmanuel macron pas de ceux dans ce
livre d'une leçon d'optimisme et d'une
leçon de vie est ce que c'est ça que
vous avez voulu montrer ce qu'on a voulu
montrer c'est se mettre à la place de
jeunes qui souvent viennent vient nous
voir et nous disent et à qui on dit ayez
confiance en vous ok comment fait pour
moi confie on ad on a des recettes voilà
pour avoir confiance en soyant
s'aperçoit finalement que les barrières
que nous nous mettons ce sont d'abord
nos propres barrières avant d'être celle
de sel de la vie
vous l'avez dit patrice à juste titre
avoir un accident philippe croizon la
manche 100 membres et qui
malheureusement sur une sur sa toiture
en train de tracter des charges
incroyable et l'ice de l'indianité les
exactement et celui je vais y arriver
parce que la jeune que je vois à la télé
ils y arrivent elles à 16 ans donc il
quelque part il s'agit d'un ouvrage et
j'ai des enfants et de jeunes enfants ça
c'était la première chose et puis non
content de se satisfaire d'avoir
traversé la manche il va faire ensuite
le le paris dakar et on a une succession
je dirais de portraits avec un fil
conducteur qui est cette motivation
cette fois on dans l'atteinte d'un
objectif en étant totalement hermétique
aux critiques aux météo à tout ce qui
peut être compliqué et on ne communique
systématiquement d'ailleurs c'est aussi
une colonne vertébrale sur les solutions
là où beaucoup de nos concitoyens
parfois communique plus tôt sur sûr où
les excuses ou rien c'est pas possible
de la main sur des on dit quand même les
français et c'est vrai le montre peu sur
le sont pessimistes ils ont on va
peut-être parler des idées jaune tout à
l'heure et c'est une sorte enfin ce sont
des gens qui
qui pense que l'avenir est un peu bouché
c'est parce que culturel être à la
différence d'autres pays
peut-être est-ce que si vous avez voulu
répondre aussi à ça en disant mais
attendez on peut peut-être y arriver
quoi moi on a voulu répondre avec un
robot sur berck est un qui est un
chercheur associé qui qui est prof lui
fait après des petits commentaires
si on a voulu maman disséqué tout ce qui
concerne les clés de la performance
et quand on s'adosse aux clés de la
performance on est capable de bousculer
des montagnes
moi j'ai souhaité que ce soit d'abord
des portraits 100% française pour ça je
me suis permis de poser devant sa
défense il a oui parce que on parle
souvent de ce qui se passe des réussites
extérieur mais regardez notre beau pays
il ya plein de choses exceptionnelles il
ya des femmes et des hommes
exceptionnels
on en a quelques trajectoires ici qui
sont des gens comme vous et nous et qui
vont rendre leur destin juste unique
extraordinaire et qui aujourd'hui sont
quelque part ou des modèles parfois
d'aider des guides faut bien se poser la
question didier deschamps cet homme là
tout réussi dans ces villes là on parle
de chat noir je le dis souvent c'est
comme une patte de lapin didier
deschamps il a été en tant que joueur
champion de france champion d'europe
champion du monde en tant qu'entraîneur
il était également champion du monde
ils ont pu aussi bien sûr champion du
monde en tant que joueur et en tant
qu'entraîneur c'est le troisième
simplement c'est exceptionnel mais
didier deschamps
il a des règles il pose un diagnostic il
se donne un objectif
l'objectif il ne le quitte plus quand
bien même et des critiques vous
permettez juste d'une petite exemple
parce qu'on va s'en rappeler la coupe de
la coupe du monde de football en russie
où j'ai eu le bonheur de pouvoir
travailler pour la fifa au bout du
deuxième match nous sommes qualifiés à
la fin du match contre le pérou ont
gagné 1-0 on est qualifié l'objectif des
chances et pas d'être premier avec les
meilleures notes qui soit en matière de
jeux où ça va vous connaissez ça puisque
au troisième match on savait qu'on était
premier didier deschamps et l'équipe de
france ont été particulièrement
critiquées après le 3 0 contre le
danemark c'est fini on a fait 0 0
qu est ce que c est fini car les
allemands qui avaient eux mêmes été
éliminés etc
mais qu'est ce qu'on attendait didier
deschamps il avait un objectif c'est
d'être produit à la fin du marathon
n'est pas du 100 m mais on l'a critiqué
beaucoup nom l'indiqué beaucoup et
aujourd'hui on va lui faire une statue
en or massif et
la france est formidablement fier
d'avoir obtenu cette deuxième étoile
il a rendu possible l'impossible je
signale qu'alison était traductrice pour
l'équipe de france de football
oui sur sur ses principales armes mais
on va peut-être pas parler de deux des
personnages discussions livre
si vous avez des renseignements que
carlos ghosn latry président il a la
triple cd live à 100% français non mais
là il parle d une carte tous
j'ai pas lu le livre je me permettrai
pas un bloc mais voilà pris 17 il
confesse que de pouvoir en parler c'est
juste le titre bien évidemment rendre
possible l'impossible c'est vrai que
c'est en gros je retiens de cette idée
que quand on veut ça commence par sa
voix quand on veut on peut
et c'est vrai que une des clés pour
réussir
mais quand la réussite est au bout parce
que ça laisse à penser que tous ceux qui
voudraient pourrait j'ai tellement de
gens autour de moi qui ont cette
capacité à vouloir se concentrer la même
façon vous le dit tellement de gens que
je connais déterminer mais qui
malheureusement n'y arriveront pas pour
demain mais c'est probablement un autre
livre qui aura un autre livre affaires
de gens qui se sont donnés les moyens
réellement avec une vraie détermination
et qu'il n'y arrive pas et là on
pourrait parler éventuellement des
échecs de certains pour des obstacles
dont on pourrait parler aux quelqu'un je
pourrais même vous parler de mon cas
personnel mais c'est pas le lieu
c'est pour dire que je rends hommage aux
outils parce que oui de la même façon on
m'a dit
un bac technique un bac technique pour
faire pharma avec un concours sachant
que c'est tous des bacs cd bac d c'est
un peu si vous avez 0,0001 % de chances
d'avoir le concours je l'ait rendue
possible parce qu'effectivement j'ai pas
écouté et donc il a effectivement cette
idée selon laquelle on doit croire en
soi pas forcément écouté et en même
temps avoir cette détermination et en
même temps on nous explique dans la vie
que c'est important d'écouter les
conseils des autres donc il ya un petit
peu ce mixte dans la vie où il faut
savoir s'entourer
c'est vrai qu'ils organisent au ils ont
fait ce qu'ils voulaient vous voulez
quand même et en même temps on explique
que dans la vie il est bon d'écouter les
conseils
ce départ est parfois des amis quand
même et enfin pour terminer ce que je
ressens la c1 rendre possible
l'impossible je pensais au cas de m bat
p mais pour le coup j'ai l'impression
que c'est l'idée selon laquelle c'était
quasiment une autoroute pour lui il est
il et il est doux et donc il a le
symptôme par définition de l'enfant qui
va réussir présidents de clubs de foot
et vous êtes un très avertis sur les
sports en général les mômes
quand ils sont bons ce que vous voulez
entre en travers de ces gens là quand
ils sont bons ils sont donc donc par
définition le possible est déjà une
possibilité qu'ils ont soit et ensuite
l'environnement c'est quasiment la
banlieue qui réussit plus que les autres
là je parle du cas du foot en
particulier un père footballeur bref il
avait du canada ils avaient toutes les
possibilités
sauf si juste avant la limite
non mais je rejoins ce que dit moustafa
à juste titre exception c'est que on
peut avoir toutes les qualités innées le
travail entraîne le talent merci le
talent entraîne la chance la réussite
pourquoi ces gens là on se dit parfois
c'est tant mieux moi je ne crois pas au
hasard
je ne crois pas lâchant je crois la
chance et la réussite quant au départ il
ya du travail
une qui entraîne le talent qui viennent
et mbappé tous les tous les portraits
que nous avons jean louis etienne jean
louis vienne qu'à une formidable formule
qui dit qu'ils disent aussi on ne
repousse pas ses limites
on les découvre il a parfaitement raison
c'est d'aller repousser ses limites
guillaume néry disait plus j'avais mal
plus j'avais envie de de dingue
et puis derrière il ya aussi cette
notion de loisir et de plaies
ir et ça je pense que c'est très
important on le retrouve chez qui la
même map et mustapha on le retrouve
également chez des gens comme claude de
claude bébéar peut paraître un peu
particulier parce que claude bébéar
intéressant avec avec l'âge l'âge lâches
qui la bataille non pas comme les autres
elles nous font date heure du groupe axa
mais nous explique qu'en trois jours ils
décident de racheter une
une assurance qui est le numéro 1 en
france cotées en bourse alors que lui à
une petite société louis d'assurance
après ça s'est mieux après ça mais il
réussit il réussi à racheter en trois
jours cette chose-là eddy plus
l'obstacle est grand plus je souhaite le
franchir ce sont des gens qui sont
avides c'est exceptionnel
jean louis etienne 72 ans on se dit il a
une vie quelque part rêver il a vraiment
été acteur de sa vie plutôt que les
spectateurs de saint john
et ben non jean louis etienne il décide
au mois de septembre de d'aller dans
dans l'océan circumpolaire avec un
immense vaisseau qui est un espèce de
coton tige 750 tonnes lester comme un
bateau contours dit je t'appelle polar
pod et il va aller travailler sur la
biodiversité
pardon mais le mec qui l'a 62 ça c'est
pas une leçon pour celles et ceux qui se
disent bon est ce que je peux faire ça
est ce que moi je crois véritablement
que le travail entraîne le talent et le
talent la réussite qui valait mbane fait
des rencontres
peut-être oui alors dire que ça c'est
important éducation voilà quelle joie ce
que dit jean charles c'est qu'il ya
aussi des rencontres où quelque chose
qui est adossé croisons c'est en voyant
une jeune roumaine de 16 ans qui
traversent la manche qui dit elle a pu
le faire
je veux pouvoir le faire puis après vous
avez les drames de la vie qui fait que
par goût les drames ou en tout cas des
choses qui sont révélatrices
la jeune zahia vous en parler et oignies
et chef d'orchestre stigmatisé par
rapport à son origine sociale est adossé
à un père en qui elle croit en qui il
est le référent le révélateur est
quelque part il ya comme souvent dans la
famille oui sur qui on peut s'habiller
exactement c'est peut être un petit peu
ce qu'on va
ce qu'on va retrouver plein bizet jean
christophe parisot qui est le seul
prêterait gagne au clac de france et qui
explique qu'il a dû et toutes les larmes
de son corps se faire mal souffrir pour
dire mais je veux y aller et je veux
travailler pour la cause de ces de ces
personnes qui sont handicapées ou qui
ont un écart peu particulier alors on
peut être très admiratif de ses
trajectoires mais ce qu'on pourrait dire
ce sont des trajectoires individuelles
c'est pas de l'ascenseur social qui a
marché je veux dire je suis pas d'accord
mais je vous posais non je suis pas
daccord patrice je suis pas d'accord
parce que ces personnes là quand on
regarde d'où elles viennent
pierre ambroise bosse mais qui a été
champion du monde olympique du 800 108
100 à londres
le mec il part avant derniers au bout de
200 m il prend un coup de coude et on se
dit et les commentateurs disent
déchaînée au revoir monsieur dame on
peut les prendre la douche et il
explique qu'il a communiqué sur le jeu
sur le plaisir et que cette finale
finalement est devenu un plaisir et dans
la souffrance plus souffrait plus sales
galvanisait est de doubler des champions
dont c'était déjà écrit et voilà ça la
grèce à l'adrénaline état est arrivé et
à la fin à la fin c'est incroyable parce
qu'il nous explique que ça s'est passé
la veille
la préparation mentale allison et il
explique que ça s'est passé la veille où
un de ses amis l'a appelé il a pris le
sèche cheveux ou d'une téléphone il a
laissé tomber la bouteille d'eau sur le
lit etc bref il était totalement étanche
à la pression naturelle qu'on peut avoir
par rapport à ça ça je pense que ce sont
aussi des messages pour ces étudiants
qui vont pas céder
voilà des examens et qui se disait c'est
pas possible si tout est possible et je
le dis aux gamins et aux jeunes qui nous
regardent parce que ces jeunes qui nous
regardent qui savent pas forcément quoi
faire encore aujourd'hui dans leur
orientation et c'est qu'ils fassent ce
qu'ils ont envie de faire la passion qui
est la leur ils se substitueront parfois
aux carences de diplômes qui n'ont pas
forcément vous ça fasse un bel exemple
par rapport à ça il nous l'a expliqué
tout à l'heure macron raclette dans
votre libre comme s'il n'avait pas fait
la préface pour coiffer la préface moi
j'appelle le président macron à minuit
brees pour à 4 heures du matin
est ce un républicain qui l'appelle et
reçoit la même obédience ou pas on peut
quand même constater former ensemble le
constat que lorsqu'il décide d'y aller
personne n'y croit c'est qui ce mec qui
sort de nulle part qui a fait un bras
d'honneur à l'apa deux parties la partie
il va se faire linge et par la gauche
etc il arrive au premier tour dit cela
ne réussira pas etc
il a quand même rendu d'un possible
rendu possible l'impossible il a encore
fait mieux
pardon de le dire c'est que moi je
prends souvent cette image du bowling du
joueur de bowling le joueur de bowling
on est trois je vais gagner la partie
non seulement je gagne la partie mais je
fais ce travail sur strike il ya pink il
ya plus le quine de gauche a plus de
quille de droite et à l'arrivée
l'exposent les codes
alors ça fonctionne où ça fonctionne pas
là aujourd'hui c'est un peu plus mitigé
sur la tv sur le sol après l'attentât
mais sur le fond je rejoins sco dijon
shall we il a rendu possible la possible
moi j'ai juste une question est ce que
si la pause par définition est ce que ça
se transmet en clair là on peut faire la
démonstration parce qu'on a les gens qui
sont aboutis à dire que on fait ce genre
ce travail que vous avez fait sur des
gens qu'on connaît et qui sont arrivés
au bout de leur parcours même si c'est
jamais terminé
mais la question c'est est-ce que à
rebours ils seraient devenus ce qu'ils
sont devenus s'ils avaient simplement
écouter des conseils et pour le dire
autrement
est ce que c'est un livre recettes alors
qu'on peut penser que par définition ce
sont des gens qui sont un peu et badra
ordinaire des gens pas de formule
magique pour contrer ça c'est quelque
chose qui vient de qui vient de très
loin
souvent souvent une référence familial
souvent une personne qui vous a
accompagnés mais cette niaque qui fait
qu'on écoute plus où on écoute les bons
mais qui continue par faire une chose
d'extraordinaire d'impossible est ce
qu'il ya une recette par définition
alors la recette on va la trouver là sur
les clés de la performance sur le fait
d'avoir extrêmement confiance comme en
latin comme fiare faire avec et aussi
faire ensemble et qu'on est évidemment
étanche à toutes les critiques ça c'est
pas donné à tout le monde mais pardonnez
moi de le dire
mustapha rahali sonne jean charles et
monsieur carmouze vous étiez bien des
gens ordinaires et on est toujours non
non non
parce que dans les trajectoires bon moi
pardon mais carmouze par exemple je suis
fan depuis je suis gamin je me sens le
mec c'est pas possible il est toujours
positif
il est toujours en train de se marrer et
on a envie d'être son pote bombay faut
nous expliquer il ya une recette matin
ici non mais je ne dis pas avec de la
flagornerie
c'est la vérité oui sortant mais il
avait en lui sert qu'il allait d'abord
ça se cultive et dans la culture ça se
travaille et je pense que racheter les
éditions comme vous l'avez faire en
randonnée c'est même plus qu'un pari
c'est un défi et une fois que vous êtes
dedans on sait que la home à celui qui
va même chercher va devoir être bon moi
c'est ce que je dis dans le sport vous
même
pardon hein vous étiez pas programmé
pour ce que vous avez fait vous le
racontez d'ailleurs c'était vous avez
vous avez fondé il une première et puis
après vous avez été à canal + avait
dirigé la rédaction de canal plus et
puis après n'hésitez pas programmé pour
devenir mère vous l'avez été
c'est aussi à chaque fois des des
challenges différents d'abord je pense
que c'est la passion pour les
réparations à la passion le travail mais
aussi le fait que ça pardonnez moi quoi
qu'on en dise dans le voit dans la rue
aujourd'hui fa la vie est belle
qu'est-ce qui peut être dramatique
oui de perdre un être cher de perdre sa
famille ça m'est arrivé là on est une
journée mais a buté à vie rires ça c'est
ça c'est un vrai sujet le reste c'est
quoi non il faut il fait savoir
il sait relativiser ah bah évidemment
moi je pense que si on n'est pas capable
de réactivité alors tout tout et tout
est formidable pour dire là aujourd'hui
fait plus froid qui hier c'est vrai que
ça car ils ont attrapé un rhume je sais
pas si je vais y aller
le demain il faut que j'aille courir et
ça va être compliqué je dis simplement
dans le sport et d'ailleurs je pense que
faire de la politique quand on vient du
sport c'est bien plus facile parce que
vous avez vous êtes imbibé aux règles du
jeu et les règles s'appliquent
ça ne s'interprète pas donc il faut
donner des règles y compris en politique
et moi je le dis en sport on peut être
battu mais si on est battu il faut que
ce soit battu par meilleur et si on est
battus par meilleurs on serre la main on
dit bravo jean charles a été meilleure
si on n'est pas battu par meilleur c'est
qu'on n'est pas bon et si on n'est pas
bon on a rien à là c'est clair
net précis moi je fonctionne comme ça
alors après
voilà ça a fonctionné comme ça vous avez
beaucoup commentée et jouer au foot et
vous fonctionné comme ça aussi dans la
politique on voit parler des mers après
oui parce que moi la première chose que
j'ai faite par exemple c'est de réunir
l'ensemble des élus de la ville de
poissy en 2014 quand j'ai des agents la
ville ne passait pas de possibles pardon
en 2014
mille agents dans le théâtre de la ville
de poissy et je leur ai donné les règles
du jeu et ma vision de la manière de
gérer dans le sens noble
cette ville où je suis né où j'ai grandi
que ma famille nombreuse etc et on a
ajusté les règles a abandonné et puis
une fois que la soirée était terminée
désormais on est dans le jeu on est hors
du jeu quand on est hors du jeu dans
politique comme dans le sport il ya une
sanction est donc est en revanche il
faut être sans état d'âme sur le fait
que quelqu'un sort du jeu et pardon de
le dire ça fonctionne plutôt bien jeune
alison ce qu'on est très franco français
non mais c'est la même chose c'était
pour moi c'était tout joueur rêve de
venir en france vivent en france et puis
voilà après 18 ans je suis toujours là
j'ai mon propre boîte
réponse c'est pas facile vous savez
ministre at il lancé c'est compliqué
mais ça me plaît j'ai des gens
formidables
comment est-ce qu'on peut arriver à
traduire les propos de ribery de leurs
parents
reiter venir sur un revenu de notre ami
sûr car le livre en particulier
moi ce qui me fascine c'est son parcours
oui totalement
pour le coup très éclectique on ne
disait presque es qui n'était pas pro le
fait pour et sa j'adore
pour une raison simple parce que quand
on dit faut pas écouter point une chose
avec elle que je n'ai jamais écouté
pense qu'on va se rejoindre là dessus
c'est le fait de dire c'est pas pareil
quand on est journaliste et qu'on dit
qu'on va faire de la politique on dit
attention tu es journaliste tu sais
faire mais vous fait pas de politique
c'est pas pareil et quand on est dans la
politique ne fait pas de
l'entrepreneuriat parce que l'entreprise
c'est pas pareil et on entend en
permanence c'est pas paraître comme s'il
fallait rester dans des cases et dans
des boîtes ne souhaite d'en sortir de
passer comme ça j'allais dire d'un d'un
d'un rail à un autre c'est une manière
effectivement de rendre les choses
possibles quand souvent on est tracé et
que ça devient un peu lassé de l'inde a
passé et ça c'est tout mon discours en
plus puisque vous dites c'est que les
bosniens c'est vrai que ceux des polars
et de la jeunesse qu'est ce que dites
vous à passer qu'effectivement il faut
surtout se dépolluer toutes ces paradis
moi je me suis pas posé de questions
savoir si c'était bien une trappe salle
est bien vu ou pas c'est vous faites
fait le chemin en équipe
parce que je pense que c'est une
aventure partagée collégiale sinon on ne
réussit rien je prends souvent cette
phrase qui dit selon bat plus vite
ensemble on va plus loin je le crois
véritablement mais oui c'est une très
belle aventure man et peut-être que
demain je serai du champ je ne sais pas
mais si un jour ça me tente vraiment un
bout sur ses os x 6 et sur le centre
d'entraînement du psg s'est fait ça a
été ça a été une longue lutte ça c'était
wiimote et à l'orgue la même manière
comment rendre possible l'impossible
c'est que quand d'autres cite sans les
nommer demandez vous l'aurez jamais
exactement ça peut paraître chez toi les
terrains sont pollués j'avais déjà signé
les terrains sont pollués moi j'ai vous
avez raison c'est pas forcément le
meilleur site m'enfin bon si jamais le
psg venait à partir à l'extérieur et en
dehors du département des yvelines ce
qui avait été évoqué fut un temps
j'aurais préféré ce que je dis mais qu'à
mes collègues maires notamment vaud sera
mieux qu'ils restent dans le département
des yvelines
donc en revanche peut-être en termes de
méthode moi je
jamais critiqué jamais être les
différents sites
les différents sites ont bien critiquer
la ville de poissy moi je me suis
focalisé on a focalisé notre énergie
notre dossier est plutôt que d'aller
voir ce qui était pas bien à l'extérieur
c'était d'aller voir les propriétaires
pour leur dire voilà on a un projet dit
nouveau prix on est allé voir le
président du conseil départemental
pierre bédier la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse le président des
agriculteurs christophe hillairet
on est allé voir le prix dans la commune
urbaine philippe poutou on s'est bien
arrangé et une fois qu'on avait signé le
73e et dernier propriétaire
on appelait paris saint-germain leur a
dit voilà il ya 74 hectares tout est
réglé
on vend à l'euro l'euro donc pas de pas
de bénéfices et j'ai souhaité qu'il y
ait pas de bénéfices par rapport à ça
pourquoi parce que vous savez comme moi
vous le savez tous et surtout la table
le paris saint germain c'est une marque
exceptionnelle il avait il fallait
gagner d'abord l'abattage pour moi la
bataille de l'image et ensuite la
bataille économique et il se trouve que
deux mois après des grands constructeurs
automobiles sont venues faisant on
aimerait bien s'installer en face du psg
oui ça va ça mais là j'ai pas vendu à
l'euro l'eau et l'installation c'est
pour quand alors on est en plein travaux
là parce que alors la france toutes ces
modalités c'est plus du millefeuille
administratif là on a clairement la
boulangerie entière
donc recherches archéologiques recherche
environnementale etc
et c'est donc là le diagnostic qui a été
fait le paris saint germain commence à
travailler il faut purger les recours
ouverture a priori en 2000 2021 avec ce
qui est exceptionnel c'est 2000 emplois
pendant la durée des travaux
c'est le football patrice mais c'est
également le handball et le heiva judo
il ya une école rouge et bleu il ya une
clinique et on a derrière plus de 500
emplois pérennes et accessoirement 2
millions d'euros de taxes annuelles pour
la communauté urbaine
on est vraiment dans le cercle vertueux
de l'économie locale sur quoi je crois
véritablement c'est-à-dire consignes une
convention avec le paris saint germain
sur les ressources locales avec des
ateliers de proximité pour que mes
jeunes puissent aller travailler
puissent être formés pour notamment les
espaces verts il a beaucoup quand vous
avez 14 terrains etc etc y compris pour
les entreprises locales qui moi je
suggère qu'elle faisait un droit de
tirage
avant peut-être avant peut-être les
doutes c'est pas forcément juridiquement
et politiquement correct de l'irlande
mais c'est ce qui va se passer
c'est en tout cas c'est une belle
victoire oui on est content mais ça va
le titre on aurait pu l'appeler
impossible n'est pas français sauf que
le deuxième tome jeu j'entends bien
pouvoir avoir le ressenti de monsieur
monsieur obama
de mesures dures federer je veux aussi
que oui je voudrais qu'on puisse avoir
la transversale aussi des expériences
qui nous montre que là où par exemple
aux états unis que connaît bien allison
on est toujours à envier pas envié
pardon mais toujours à s'imprégner de la
réussite de l'autre mais il voit en
france culturellement d'ailleurs de
prison on est plutôt à jalouser sa
cellule il a racheté les éditions la
joie ni ça c'est le chien loup là on va
regarder un peu ce qui se passe alors
que aux etats unis outre manche c'est
formidable en charge bien sûr qu'elle
préside vers la côte est qu'est ce
qu'une balise on sait ce que c'est c'est
le passé le père vit en fait c'est ça
l'intelligence
les journées ce qui pose de bonnes
questions des présidents sont quand même
corps ticket oui qui font de belles et
interviews mais alors que l'actualité
les gilet jaune est évidemment est ce
que au four n'incite pas au tour de
france ce qui épate de france une france
dont une france d'en bas une france
mondialisé et une forte marque canalisée
est-ce que c'est pas ça au fond le lait
les gilet jaune français un peu
effrayante
quand on voit les images quand on entend
les gilet jaune s'exprimer revendiqué on
comprend pas tout
d'un strict point de vue linguistique on
va tout ce qu'ils disent c'est déjà mais
quand on arrive à comprendre ce qu'ils
disent
on comprend pas pourquoi est ce que
c'est le gasoil est ce que c'est
l'augmentation du prix du cadre du des
carambars sources différentes
ce que non mais c'est faux mais cet
homme c'est vrai alors pour le coup le
mot et les choses termine juste pour des
choses qui sont quand même quand on
regarde vraiment de près l'augmentation
du coût du diesel c'était un truc est
quasiment ridicule enfin je veux dire en
euros constants c'est pas plus cher
qu'il ya sept ans je veux dire on sait
très bien que là dessus sans fin aucune
discussion ne fin il ya quand même beau
là il n'y a pas de la langue
peut-être des tasses peut-être les uns
trop peut-être une véritable goulet
france parce que la communication si je
pense que c'est pas le grand fort de ce
gouvernement fait très souvent ils font
des erreurs monstrueuses c'est que là en
un minimum de temps il ya eu la
limitation à 80 kilomètres à l'heure le
renchérissement du contrôle technique le
nombre de points de contrôle technique
le stationnement absolument impossible
dans toutes les villes de france avec le
multiplication par dix du prix d'une
amende
le tarif d impressionner qui ont donc
tous notre chalet ce qu'on appelait la
vache à lait avec surtout une
reconnaissance du du tissu français qui
les français on adore nos voitures et
c'est vraiment c'est un truc auquel
fopaht vous fallait pas toucher alors il
touché cinq fois de suite en moins de
trois semaines
là on se dit c'est quasiment suicidaire
après j'ai bien c'est quand même
terrible
et puis surtout alors après je vous
laisse la parole mais emmerder les
français alors en comprend pas très pas
du tout le mode d'action et de bloquer
les péages je passe même pas ce que l'on
va pas mettre tout le monde dans le même
panier mais les propos racistes
homophobes rennais les propos violents a
été levée de cette femme voilée qui
s'est fait arracher son voile je sais si
j'ai pas pour le port du voile
enfin gta c'est totalement scandaleux et
tout ça on bloque on bloque les trucs on
fout des commerçants dans la merde on
emmerde tout le monde pourquoi ça
emmerde tout le monde sauf le
gouvernement ce qu'est une colère parce
que derrière cette colère qui est
difficile c'est peut être en colère et
j'achète chez jean-charles dit tu parles
d'une france effrayante
parce que c'est vrai que c'est un peu
c'est un peu le général aurait dit la
chienlit
mais moi j'aurai j'ai pensé à autre
chose tout a été dit sur cette affaire
que ces partis du prix du gasoil donc
des taxes ça veut dire des prélèvements
ensuite on est passé à haut pouvoir
d'achat finalement ce qu'il dit c'est
pas le pouvoir d'achat mais c'est plutôt
le reste à vivre pour acheter des choses
qu'on a qu'on envie de s'acheter au delà
de ce qu'on a besoin
donc il ya plein de choses qui ont été
dites ensuite c'est le ras-le-bol
fiscale mais c'est également le
ras-le-bol du politique
tout est prêt voyez les choses que j'ai
pas entendu et qui rejoint ce que tu es
10 qui vient d'être dit par l'engin
s'est j'ai l'impression qu'ils étaient
effrayés par quoi j'ai eu le sentiment
que c'était essentiellement des gens de
province par que attrape on aurait pu
imaginer que c'est une question de tout
voir de schaerbeek beaucoup on aurait pu
imaginer que dans des dans des banlieues
où par définition il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont paupérisée comparer ma compagne
niveau de vie qu'on pourrait pour l
ordre leur souhaiter ou qui
souhaiteraient pour eux mêmes on n'a pas
vu finalement de 2 de jean émerger ni
dans des mouvements ni même bloquer quoi
que ce soit et donc j'ai eu le sentiment
que ça venait essentiellement de la
province de 2,2 de ville plutôt moyenne
et moi j'ai senti qu'il était plus
effrayé qu'il ne devenait effrayant
c'est à dire que je ressens ces gens là
qui sont rire bien des centres de
décideurs peuvent vraiment loin de
travail loin de finalement la de là où
on peut acheter dont on peut consommer
et qu'on allait les priver à terme de
leurs moyens de mobilité leur moyen de
locomotion et on a touché quelque chose
de sacré donc du coup c'est il faut que
je garde ma bagnole il faut que je
puisse bouger avec ma bagnole il faut
que je puisse m'acheter tout le monde
parce que la bagnole c'est tout
simplement
les sens c'est également à chaque fois
qu'il fait un excès de vitesse tu peux
prendre 135 euros et sa claque tout le
monde à la fin laisse penser les autres
il ya une espèce de frayeur de où les
gens se disent je sais pas si à terme
je garderai cette autonomie et que et
donc du coup on parle de plein d'autres
choses mais c'est plus de la voiture
dont on parle en réalité donc la goutte
qui fait déborder non pas le réservoir
parce qu'ils ont du mal à faire le plein
mais c'est cette vous de corée fait
déborder le vase au sens où ils vont se
sentir demain quasiment privé liberté
laissez le président des riches et des
villes et donc par définition pas celui
des pauvres et la province de l'espèce
de frayeur pendant presque inexploré
n'est pas très loin du livre parce que
c'est c'est presque votre livre sens
inverse
mais je faisais des examens mais d'aider
des gens qui n'en ai d autres y pense
que c'est devenu impossible à impulser
ça non moi je partirai je ne partage pas
du tout ce qui a été dit là ce n'est ni
par jean-charles et par mostafa je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que le
président macron et trahi sur la
marchandise puisqu'il a été élu sur des
réformes des réformes qui sont
obligatoires dans notre pays avec 2300
milliards de dette
donc il faut absolument faire quelque
chose sinon et rattrape on est rattrapé
par la patrouille avec l'europe
et comme nous les maires ont peut être
sous l'autel et c'est ma part du contrat
sur le fond sur le fond c'est exactement
le diagnostic et dieu sait et je suis
donc républicain je ne suis pas en
marche
ce que je constate simplement c'est que
sur la forme et jean charles a parlé de
communication donc de faire savoir
là c'est catastrophique et c'est
catastrophique parce que dans cette vème
république
on est dans un travers systématique la
verticalité verticalité on est là haut
on décide on impose
et une fois qu'on a décidé on vient dire
qu'est ce que vous en pensez ben voilà
les la réponse c'est léger les jaunes et
les gilet jaune c'est pas simplement la
campagne moi hier j'étais sur le tronçon
à 13 jusqu'après vernon sont
particulièrement organisés ils vont je
rejoins ce que disait jean charles
ils vont casser le développement
économique en laissant passer les
automobilistes en arrêtant les poils ou
à l'eau
puis acheminées les matières premières
dans les entreprises etc c'est
particulièrement voulu mais nous avons
ici des gens qui peut être pour la
première fois manifeste ça s'était
jamais vu avant qu'ils ne veulent pas
voir ni les politiques et ils ont bien
raison
et moi si j'étais à gauche comme à
droite je le suis à droite je me tairai
jeu balaierait devant ma porte
alors ce n'est pas le cas on n'a pas de
leçon à donner par rapport à ça et puis
deuxièmement derrière on a une grande
pour moi frange de la population
française qui est exaspérée par cette
compilation systématique chez nous ça va
vous l'avez rappelé de taxation au même
titre que nous les nerfs jeunes standard
ce que je peux vous montrer
c'est assez intéressant parce que la
première préoccupation ça reste quand
même l'emploi mais regardez les
les taxes les impôts c'est presque aussi
haut niveau de l'eau
c'était beaucoup beaucoup moins fort
autrefois il ya quelques mois et
quelques dents alors il ya une sur de
ras-le-bol comme la réponse des mères la
réponse des mères la réponse des
français
les gilets jaunes la réponse de certains
maires sap été le cas à poissy parce que
je pense qu'en mon nom il faut qu'on
soit vraiment responsable et savoir ce
que nous souhaitons moi ce que je
souhaite c'est que la france gagne ne
sais pas comme je le dis souvent je me
lève pas le matin mais je me fais une
politique de droite une petite gauche
vous dit je vais faire la politique est
en adéquation avec celle de mes
administrés
la réponse des maires ça a été on va
trés tout y est pour la taxe
d'habitation qui fait que là où le
gouvernement il dit elle va baisser
new holland de communes elles ont
augmenté 1 ça ça aussi c'est un très
mauvais signal mais la même manière je
parlais de verticalité je vous donne un
exemple les emplois aidés c'est pas la
panacée des emplois aidés on sait très
bien que c'est un pansement sur les
jambes de bois on connaisse bien ça dans
les acides dans les associer dans les
associations dans les collectivités
sauf que plutôt que de nous dire au mois
de juin mesdames et messieurs les élus à
partir de janvier 2019
il ya plus d'emplois et de riz mettons
nous autour de la table pour voir
comment nous substituons cela et comme
on arrive à pallier parfois des petites
ou moyennes villes ou des petites ou
moyennes associations qui ont besoin
cela qu'est ce qui s'est passé mois de
juin mi-juillet fin des emplois aidés
c'est ça la concertation s'est pas
adressé aux terrassements
recentralisation agen 20 oui
le président l'a dit ce que nous ce
qu'on lui dit simplement c'est que
aujourd'hui les communes où on nous
donne wiotte où nous nous et de nos
their exode exonère pardon un certain
nombre de compétences le développement
économique la politique de la ville la
compétence sportive la compétence
culturelle
il faut pas qu'on devienne des chambres
d'enregistrement la république 17 sans
rien ne s'est passé pas on arrive à nous
quatre c'est vous qui créez 36000
communes
on peut pas dire la règle et qu'on le
relâche à travers et puis dire derrière
les communes ont fait comme s'ils
n'existaient plus et vous allez voir que
dans votre sondage dans le sauvage que
vous avez montré évoqué l' comme
deuxième cause de ras-le-bol et les
impôts et taxes
ça va être le prochain choc ça va être
fin janvier quand les feuilles de creil
le premier elle est loin la source parce
que là ça a été relativement bien
expliquer mais les gens et vous réserve
wazir génial donc moins 200 300 400
euros noyau c'est-à-dire ça va être
dramatique
ça ça peut être un cas un carnage je
reviens à ce que je disais pardon parce
que c'est en rapport avec le livre
j avais regardées du tourisme d'affairé
dit ok j'ai enfin qui était assez
provocateur avec été assez intéressant
je trouve
c'était dans les échos qui disait c'est
pas macro qui n'écoutent pas les
français c'est les français qui découpe
pas macro bas sur le frein et laissons
la face à la verve prône une sorte
d'optimisme et et vous c'est ça aussi
que vous allez chercher qu'est ce que le
question les forces qu'on peut qu'on
peut avoir et il ya un certain nombre de
gens qui se sentent exclus de sa g60
peut-être qu'ils disent mais je ne serai
jamais je ne serai jamais un croissant
je ne serai jamais un bape et je ne
serai jamais indécents les c'est génial
pour les relaxer
c'est pas un coin de votre livre
l'erreur de base c'est d'avoir pu penser
que les réformes allaient se passer
parce que tous les français responsable
constate bien qu'il faut apporter sa
petite pierre pour désendetter
layton pour moi ça a été un mauvais
diagnostic de départ pour reprendre une
une image de pharmaciens la deuxième
chose c'est que jamais on est venu
d'abord expliquer aux français ce qu'ils
ce qu'il en était et on n'a pas fait les
confiance aux premiers concernés
je prends le cas de la ville de poissy
pardon pas d'avis le possible que je
connais tous petits pas
nous sommes la seule commune de france à
préparer nos conseils municipaux dans
les quartiers tous les mois tous les
mois avec 200 250 personnes il n'y a pas
un seul recours je touche du bois pour
la ville de poissy depuis quatre ans
pourquoi parce que tout simplement on va
d'abord voir les administrer les
premiers acteurs qui sont les premiers
concernés
il valide nous décidons le sommet
politique nous sommes là pour diriger
mais on doit valider aujourd'hui tout ce
que nous faisons par rapport à la grosse
bêtise la grosse connerie
aujourd'hui nous avons des députés qui
sont hors sol mais pas seulement leur
faute c'est normal qu'ils soient au sol
il ya plus du tout de possibilités de
cumul des mandats s'incliner finalement
c'est moi je voudrais c'est une énorme
bêtise et je suis très à l'aise puisque
je suis étudiant en lettres le maire et
donc mais pourquoi vous avez parfois
déserté alors pas dans ma serre qu mais
vous êtes parfois des députés on a des
cérémonies patriotiques ou je vois bien
les anciens combattants 10e
mustapha c'est pas ta place là c'est la
place du porte drapeau
enfin je veux dire on en est là où vous
avez des députés qui pendant la campagne
on distribue des tracts dans des villes
qui ne faisait pas partie de la sirc
longtemps mais on en rit mais c'est ce
qui s'est passé et ses députés l'ont été
parfaitement nouveau aussi dans l'eau
est bas et métiers en face de moi quand
vous apprenez l'école du journalisme
vous n'avez pas forcément faire de la
formation de boucher même pas ce que je
dis donc il faut qu'on soit congruent
par rapport à sa rage et là on est au
sol juste d'aarschot on est hors sol par
rapport à ça et là on a vraiment le
sentiment d'ailleurs regardez la
composition du gouvernement pour voir
quelles sont celles et ceux qui ont été
maires parce que quand vous êtes maire
vous savez ce qui se passe rien on va
parler d elle aussi un moment deux
heures de sport aux agents dans le cas
du temps de travail par semaine j'ai
diminuer l'absentéisme de 750 g
cent mille euros d'économies il a 80
communes qui le font aujourd'hui là où
je me suis fait penser à l'époque mr fox
à dire ne vous dit rien je pense aux
jeux qu'outil à dire parce qu'on n'est
pas la même chose sur le diagnostic que
d'ailleurs je mets entre les mains des
médecins et non pas des pharmaciens
c'est plutôt le médicament est le remède
justement c'est celui ci c'est que je
vous entends et je vous suis sur le
raisonnement donc on n'est pas du tout
en désaccord sur le ce qui me gêne c'est
qu'on a on plaque des raisonnements on
plaque des analyses sur une situation où
des gens moi je le crois je le ressens
comme ça finalement ne sont même pas
concertée d'une part et en même temps
s'il n'y a pas une analyse aussi
profonde où il on parle de la situation
globale du pays c'est leur vie qui les
interdit d'ailleurs se dégage de cette
peur individuel que je ressens quand je
dis c'est plus a ressenti une peur qui
sont presque en train de se projeter
dans l'avenir en disant on va pas y
arriver on n'aura plus jamais nos
bagnoles encore une fois je leur ai je
répète je pense à ces gens qui
manifestent réellement et qui sont
vraiment dans la province et qui sont
loin des centres de décisions voire des
centres de communication
c'est pour ça que je parle plus de
ressenti et nous on essaie tous et vous
le faites
on le fait tous de mettre des
raisonnements de plaquer aisé de
comprendre oui dans le ciel du bandama
en quoi quand quelqu'un est effrayée on
essaie de comprendre quoi un moment
donné le sait les coudes d'une part et à
un moment donné et c'est trouver des
solutions mais la chercher dans l'idée
que voilà il ya un endettement
il y a on est arrivé au ras-le-bol
fiscale tout ça nous on le sait on
plaque c'est un ami il faut bien c'est
parce que j'ai écrit à la vie ressentent
et je vais te lâche terminera là dessus
l'etna telle est la télé quand même un
effet un effet loupe terre qu'on a 10
personnes par jour
il se passe à la télé oui
des médias français
au bas mot il ya deux cent cinquante
mille manifestants c'est ce que j'ai pu
comprendre à la télé régulièrement on
fait passer deux trois dix personnes qui
sont vraiment touchés dans leur chair on
a même vu quelqu'un pleurer on parle de
sa situation et celle de son enfant et
donc ça donne un effet loupe absolument
magistral
ce qui nous est instantanément ne sait
pas les seuls mouvements sur le chemin
que je parle de 1 200 âmes se marrer je
reproche à l'intérieur du stade et donc
comment vous avez comme vous regardez sa
religion ne comprendriez un moment il
faut dire c'est cinq centimes là c'est
son tour à la de salaire et combien le
litre d'essence aux états unis
ce très peu cher faites vos calculs
samedi viennent à paris je voulais juste
vous montrer ce petit chose qu'on trouve
sur le club d'être regardés on va
bloquer la circulation auto paris est ce
que c'est une faillite des partis
politiques
bon ben je crois que la faille des
partis politiques elle existe déjà nommé
ce que ça c'est un élément de plus oui
oui c'est long c'est cette bavure une
des conséquences d'un manque
d'organisation total et de la faculté de
se rassembler mais dans tous les partis
c'est à dire que gwen droite
on n'a rien à envier à personne ce qui
est inquiétant c'est pas une feuille non
plus parce que tu n'as fait des partis
politiques c'est quand même un peu une
catastrophe alors moi je suis tout à
fait autre chose qui la fait prom
annonce que je suis tout à fait de votre
avis il a été élu sur un programme fait
son coin et je souhaite qu'il le liquide
le poursuivre et c'est très bien et
c'est très bien comme ça mais dynamiter
les partis politiques ça a été bien mais
les partis politiques c'est quand même
là par moment pas dans tous mes oeufs
faut quand même on est censé réfléchir
discuter et à protéger soi même et on
voit quand même que dans la région mais
on aimerait qu'ils discutent un petit
but d'avancé avant de parler nommé dans
la démocratie le rôle des partis
politiques c'est justement de prendre en
charge les mécontentements et de les
exprimer ou dans le temps et berry dans
l'eau parlement et c'est là on voit bien
qu'ils aient plus ce rôle là et c'est
directement le voilà des gens qui équipe
prennent en main leur après ce que
faisait mustapha est quand même juste et
donc là rien il ya il parle de 250 mille
personnes sur une population de plus de
60 millions de français
il ya quand même plus de gens qui n'ont
pas gilet jaune comme si les jaunes
c'est vrai qu'on a un peu l'impression à
regarder les informations on ne serait
plus assuré que ji et jaune n'exagérons
pas non plus les dom
je voudrais vous parler du chiffre de la
semaine alors elle aussi ses 49% mais
49% de poids quand nous % de garçons 51%
de danse de la scala ici de la semaine
la jolie et que jeudi grâce de pardon
non les taxations 49 % des mères à huy
souhaite ne pas se représenter à l'issue
de leur mandat
c'est à dire qu'il ya à une sorte de
ras-le-bol c'est vrai qu'on dit que
c'est là la fonction de la dmr celle et
lui a porté deux gifles au disque des
françoises à ses suivants pour lesquels
on foncera du grenelle 2
de là c'est beaucoup quand même un oui
bien sûr de quoi alors après certains
ont connu l'âge d'or
j'irai avant la crise de 2008 on connaît
l'âge de pierre
aujourd'hui il faut faire avec et
contourner jeune élu depuis 2014 que
vous ayez 30 40 60 ans naît et on a
affaire à un défi plutôt qui est presque
à celui d'un chef d'entreprise
d'abord parce que nous quand on rend les
budgets qu'on présentait mais il faut
qu'il soit équilibré à la différence de
l'état et parfois des entreprises
deuxième mandat comme des compétences
qui fout le camp et là faut comprendre
on a des collègues qui sont élus parfois
depuis deux trois mandats ont toujours
décidé qu ont toujours créé qu'on coûte
toujours façonnées avec laure décision
aujourd'hui ce ne sont plus leur
décision puisque les compétences de
développement économique de politique de
la ville
encore une fois sport culture etc sont
confiés ou une agglomération comme
dirait comme une commune urbaine etc
donc ça c'est compliqué et puis a
toujours pas de statut à patrice demain
l'élu est battu et touchent pas le
chômage
je veux moi par exemple faire après
immobilier on me dit monsieur le maire
vous avez un statut précaire donc alors
penser que le maire passe son temps aux
petits fours autre clé ou machin ça
c'est l'image les matches des finales et
moi je vois beaucoup surtout de de
déception de frustration de tristesse de
mes collègues qui sont là depuis des
années qu'il faut un formidable boulot
moi je dis souvent si j'étais à bordeaux
je voterai les yeux fermés tous les
jours pour alain juppé si j'étais à
dijon je voudrais tous les jours pour
françois rebsamen
parce que l'élu encore une fois c'est
vraiment la personne piquée
c'est la rencontre entre on dit bien
entre des administrés avec un homme ou
une femme et l'enfant la perte nette est
la personnalité pendant préféré des
français
l'homme s'était intéressante voilà
c'était c'était pendant longtemps la
personne qui a faim parmi les hommes
politiques c'est la fonction pourrait
faire et des français c'est le c de la
personnalité avec laquelle ils peuvent
discuter qui aux proches d'eux s'est
même fois en même temps assez jouissif
je pense pour les gens qui l'exercent
parce qu'il voit tout de suite assez
vite en tout cas les résultats de leur
politique et on a quand même un sur deux
qui ne veulent plus se représenter dans
une crise quoi il ya une crise parce que
d'abord on a on a tellement je pense
critiqué le personnel politique
depuis quelques années en disant que
c'était tous des pourris s'étaient
touchés par 2 5 mai et ici c'est
l'échappée à ça mais finalement tout
tout est englobé naudin dans la même
chose on oublie complètement calé le
blick et le véritable boulot d'un maire
on oublie la charge incroyable de
travail
quand on pense qu'il ya encore des gens
effectivement voulez vous le rappeler
qu'un qui pensent que le maire c'est
quelqu'un qui va se battre et de petits
fours toutes les 10 minutes et c'est
d'une bêtise de penser ça mais
franchement beaucoup de français qui le
pense mais je dire que les français
aillent
je rentre dans les conseils municipaux
qui voit un petit peu calé le boulou et
c'est pour ça que le travail qu'il est
resté très bien et le respect après
avoir ôté ses publics un ville de poissy
40000 habitants 93 millions d'euros de
budget 70 millions 70 métiers pardon
différents et un budget
d'investissements tous les ans d'à peu
près entre 15 et 20 millions indemnités
du maire 3400 euros
alors je m'en plains pas absolument pas
mais c'est vrai quand je fais le calcul
le ratio entre les heures passées et
l'indemnité globale que je peux
percevoir
je bosse à 8 euros 50 de l'heure je ne
m'en plains pas parce que c'est une
véritable place aux voix là mais j'ai eu
ma société de production avec eux choisi
auparavant et c'est sans commune mesure
avec le salaire que je pouvais avoir
auparavant et je ne blâme pas du tout
par france tel dirigeant d'une boîte 97
millions de livres 14,2 budget je dirais
gagnerez un bémol les statistiques sur
la forme la plus élaborée du mensonge
49% des mers sous ne seraient pas
satisfaits me brosse représenterait pas
sur un mandat sauf qu'il ya 36000
communes
combien de maires de grandes communes ne
voudrait pas se rendre dans les 49 ce
que je veux dire c'était souvent des
6000 communes et sur son décolleté
que font quasiment le même boulot sur
qui touche à tous les corps de métiers
que notre ami ils ont parlé 40000
habitants ils en ont deux trois mines
donc en fait ils font le même boulot ils
n'ont pas la même rémunération ils
passent autant de temps
et à ce niveau de janvier dire de
travail pour la rémunération et pour ce
que ça un pacte avec toutes les
compétences qui partent et surtout pour
les plus petites moi qui ai une
concentration des cons on veut une
concentration des communes on va vers
les grandes agglos et donc je pense que
dans les 49 % il serait sympathique de
vérifier qu'elles sont surreprésentés au
delà de ravenhill ou trente mille
habitants j'ai droit dans 51 % des mères
qui veulent se représenter visiblement
bien donc ce que prévoit la loi y ont
posé ici en était si on était sur les
vingt trente mille peut-être que 90 %
des mères se représentera il n'y a pas
que ça
c'est que aujourd'hui c'est un véritable
parcours d'obstacles de pouvoir rendre
un budget équilibré puisque à poissy par
exemple la dotation globale de
fonctionnement en pertes cumulées entre
2014 et 2020 sera de 28 millions d'euros
avec des transferts de compétences qui
chaque année représente 500 mille euros
j'ai quelques exemples les passeports
les pacs maintenant ça se passe en mai
les pacsés un pacs se passe se passe en
mairie
ces cinq cent mille euros qui viennent
se rajouter à cette bête à cette baisse
de la dgf qui viennent se rajouter
également à un nombre de services à la
population croissant parce que nos
administrés on peut les comprendre sont
de plus en plus sont de plus en plus
exigeant donc à l'arrivée
si vous n'êtes pas vigilants que vous ne
gérez pas votre mairie comme une
entreprise vous êtes rapidement sous
tutelle est ce qu'on constate c'est que
vous avez un budget qui lui va être
quasiment constant avec des dépenses qui
sont ras les pâquerettes 5 millions
d'euros d'économies de fonctionnement -
moi je décide de donner quatre cent
mille euros à mai à mes agents parce que
j'estime que si jamais les agents ne
relève pas le défi dans ce contrat
gagnant gagnant
alors on y va on augmente la pression
fiscale ce que je me refuse de faire qui
échappe à la tutelle
anne hidalgo par exemple beaucoup plus
de mal visiblement à gérer son budget le
géant - bien que moins bien que vous
je voulais juste vous justement tu étais
et c'était un rapport récent le 110ème
l'impossible ce qu'on a tweeté tweet le
tweet de la semaine voilà bah c'est le
vôtre
justement vous expliquer voilà que les
la baisse drastique des dépenses de
fonctionnement de la ville
et c'est au tour de force de maintenir
la variété des qualités des services aux
habitants de poisson oui mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle c'est pas
simplement une équation la race fière
non mais c'est mettre en place un plan
d'amélioration des conditions de travail
mais il ya aussi hors joue un petit peu
le livre c'est à dire qu'il ya aussi
deux façons de lire les difficultés
telles que l'on peut soit baisser les
bras
soit se dit heureusement là évidemment
et puis je pense que je garde donc je
disais mais juste pour qu'on rigole
ensemble quand je propose de donner deux
heures de sport à mai à mes agents d'une
par semaine dans le cas du temps de
travail
j'ai un coup de téléphone de mon party
les républicains pour lui mais tu es
complètement barjo on a deux mois des
élections il ya trop de fonctionnaires
en france il faut en virée et toi tu vas
leur donner il vous dit rien et c'est à
dire une ennemie mois et des mois rond
les badges ont badge les agents donc il
faut leur durée légale du temps de
travail par semaine 37 eur 10 c'est pas
35 ans et 37 eur 10 et encore une fois
j'ai réussi l'exploit l'exploit ont
réussi ce que j'ai expliqué sur le
budget l'économie et à l'arrivée on
génère 100 mille euros d'économie on a
des agents qui gêne qui sont plus en
forme parce qu'ils ont participé pendant
deux heures et puis derrière où j'arrive
à réinvestir sur les cent mille aux
quarante mille euros pour du matériel
ergonomique des fauteuils un meilleur
éclairage etc
donc c'est un contrat gagnant gagnant si
on ne comprend pas ça l'est pour
comprendre ça il faut être sur le
terrain
108 milliards sans humilier à patrice
108 milliards d'euros d' absentéisme en
france qu'est ce qu'on ferait on y
travaille on fait semblant j'avais
envoyé une lettre à tous les médecins
généralistes de la région leur disant si
vous pensez qu'à une pathologie avec le
travail quand vous voyez des patients
qui sont agents de la collectivité
dites le nous envoyer les s'il vous
plaît la médecine du travail médecine
indépendante et peut-être qu'il ya une
pathologie qui peut être réglé que c'est
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas d'hier mais ans
je me suis fait j'ai fait la ville a dit
vous intervenez dans thurella l'humanité
je vous aime ou pas mais à l'arrivée
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mais c'est
comme partout il ya des brebis galeuses
vous avez aussi des gazelles chez les
médecins généralistes parfois en toute
toute minorité et c'est un travail
gagnant gagnant on va pas faire des murs
entre une collectivité
les médecins les hôpitaux on est tous
dans la même galère fasse tourner un
petit peu responsables après je rejoins
ce que dit moustafa tout à l'heure moi
ils le voient concrètement au quotidien
pour le pouvoir d'achat mais administrés
d'abord parce que je donne notamment 30
euros de coûts de licence en moins à
toutes les personnes qui font qu'ils
sont dans une association sportive et
culturelle entre 12 et 17 ans ça c'est
du pouvoir d'achat en plus je donne une
pochette scolaires de proximité pour la
rentrée scolaire de 20 euros sans
quotient familial
ça c'est du pouvoir d'achat c'est toutes
ces petites gouttes nous venons
carrément donné nous venons d'en bas
c'est du concret mais ça vous le faites
pas ce que vous êtes sur le terrain donc
que moi quand j'entends des leçons
morales là haut en disant vous allez
voir il ya qu'à faut qu'on
ben y'a pas de souci non vous attend
tous les jours si on lui milliards c'est
le danger privée vie publique
l'attentisme en français sans lui me
diallo est là qui est fait pas partie
des 49 % des mères qui veulent pas se
représenter c'est le maire de trappes
sevgi balanda qui a je crois 81 ans qui
était depuis 2001 et qui a annoncé qu'il
allait se représenter
non c'est chez vous c'est pateras en
effet les noms qui fait partie de ces
alors ça serait pas vous de se présenter
fait partie des quinze son bus de mer
depuis trente mille habitants messieurs
fait partie des 90 % qui se représente
au web mais voit bien
c'est sympa de me voir là bas je vais y
sourit parce que comment dire maintenant
on est content on écoute on écoute en
cas qui a une qui a eu finalement
plusieurs vies et qui est qui est maire
d'une grande commune a vu deux offres à
près de zéro c'est fait pour être
sérieux
attrapons vous nous écoutez ailleurs je
les dis moi je les dis à mes ce
malandain gelé dit un monsieur fort
rouge les dit à monsieur rabais j'ai dit
à monsieur masseron j'ai dit à tous ces
gens là il ya maintenant quelques mois
les yeux dans les yeux que j'envisageais
effectivement en tous les cas d'y
réfléchir fortement oui parce que après
tout c'est c'est pas rendre impossible
pour le coup l'impossible mais j'ai pas
de voilages et pas une envie personnelle
enfin de dire que c'est parce que vous
êtes élus et associatifs
c'est vrai que ça fait quinze ans
maintenant que sur trappe c'est vrai
qu'on a eu on a eu de beaux parcours
collectif que ce soit dans le foot ou
dans l'associatif parapharmacie toile
c'est vrai que j'aurais envie de
franchir le cap maintenant la forme que
ça prendra je ne sais pas si c'est tête
de liste ou si c'est au contraire avec
une liste voilà d'union j'allais dire
d'union municipal mais j'ai pas
d'ambition personnelle ça c'est une
certitude
par contre j'ai une vraie ambition pour
pour des projets c'est à dire que on a
beaucoup parlé ici autour de cette table
de l'ump est saint tricat j'en ai parlé
souvent chiche à l'ump donc j'en profite
pour le dire il y a carle qui le disait
tout à l'heure à dijon c'est plutôt
raide semaine et un bordeaux c'est
plutôt juppé en clair dans les
municipalités on a besoin ps d'un côté
voilà pourquoi je suis très très heureux
de participer à une liste d'union des
mains voila vous le dis municipal mais
je le dis depuis maintenant quelques
mois aux intéressés qui sont eux dans la
politique j'en suis pas un mais mais
voilà je pense que on peut travailler au
redressement
alors monsieur malandain bien évidemment
mais ressortant envie de continuer ça je
peux le comprendre parce que c'est il
s'est pris de passion pour cette ville
et il a fait de mélodies
il veut donc l'on veut donc continuer
c'est juste que j'ai cru comprendre
qu'il n'allait rien n'ira pas jusqu'au
bout
la seule chose qu'on voudrait savoir
c'est qui prendrait sa succession je
pense qu il le dira rapidement j'espère
parce que les trappistes doivent savoir
quand même par qui ils peuvent être
administrés et mais sinon à part ça
voilà on sera on sera pas rivaux on sera
probablement probablement concurrents
par contre ton proposer autre chose et
rendre possible ce qui probablement pour
certains est impossible état possible
et ben voilà c'était une belle
conclusion de cette émission va suivre
un petit peu ce qui va ce qui va se
passer car le livre merci infiniment
vaincu et patrice heures je rappelle le
type des livres rendre possible
l'impossible c'est donc ces ballons et
donc ses seize portraits voilà que vous
pouvez le dire parce qu'on va pour
beaucoup de choses sur ces gens là et
puis ça peut devenir des exemples
allison sikorski merci infiniment son
retour un ouvrier puis à lancer la
prochaine fois on fait des missions en
anglais et jean-charles je dis merci
beaucoup
à bientôt à très vite pour un nouveau
numéro de profs
[Musique]